tyrese gibson's mother priscilla murray
has died after battling covet 19 and
pneumonia
you fought man he fought
oh my god i'm so sorry this happened
that's the actor holding on to his mom's
hand as he tearfully says goodbye
i'm gonna hold your hand for the rest of
my life okay
everywhere i go
i'm gonna hold your hand
it's the way you held my hand when i was
a kid
tyrese writes in part quote this is the
saddest moment of my life my sweet
valentine just passed away we as a
family are broken and just can't believe
this
now fans friends and fellow celebs are
rallying around the actor including his
baby boy co-star snoop dogg who lost his
mother in october
the rapper writes quote stay strong i'll
come see you this week if you like to
pray with you and hug you
earlier this month tyrese first told
fans about his mother's health revealing
that she was in the icu following her
diagnosis and he asked for prayers on
social media behind this door
is my mom right there i'm sitting in a
hallway
because they told me i can only be in
there with her while she has covert
for 30 minutes at a time right now i'm
in icu
and
i can ask y'all to pray for my mom
the singer shared this photo of the
hallway outside his mother's hospital
room and shared an upsetting update
quote the doctor sat in this chair and
just broke my heart by telling me
there's pretty much nothing else that
can be done to turn things around
but he didn't lose hope posting this pic
holding her hand simply writing keep
fighting mother please mother we need
you
all i want is for her to continue to
inhale
and exhale
that's all i want
last week tyreese shared this throwback
clip from the oprah winfrey show when he
surprised his mom with a house
so priscilla tyrese is here and he
brought along the rest of the family
to come all the way from watts to out
here
night and day this represents mother you
don't have to cry no more
and tyrese's mom got one more special
tribute before she died from legendary
saxophonist kenny g this is to your mom
with my best wishes thank you
[Music]
victoria's gonna play for you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the singer writes in the caption kenny g
just blessed my mother sir i am forever
indebted for what you just did for my
mother and the world amen
[Music]